okay so pretty much every comic book
story stars an orphan
having dead parents seems to be a
prerequisite to being a superhero
so it's nice that invincible breaks the
mold and gives us a loving and generous
father
in omni wait what the hell is he doing
well it turns out that omniman is one of
the biggest super villains ever
viewing human life as something weak and
meaningless omniman has no problem
wiping people out in their thousands
just to prove a point
and he even refers to the woman he loves
as nothing more than a pet
he's pretty much what would happen if
homelander had a baby with breitbart
and the guy is one of the worst super
powered people that you could ever come
across
so what should you do if you're ever in
a fight with him or
just so happen to be unlucky enough to
be on a train that he's forcing his
son's face through
well i can't help much with the last one
but in this video we're gonna be
discussing the characters weaknesses
whilst also giving our plan of attack on
how to take him down
full spoilers ahead as well as some
parts of the comics that the show hasn't
got to yet
so if you don't want anything ruined
then i recommend that you check out now
if you enjoy the video then please smash
the thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this each
and every day
without the way a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into
how to beat omniman okay so veltromites
are pretty
the race comes from a planet of
supremacists in which only the strong
were allowed to survive
and all the weak were killed off to make
way for them selective breeding and
eugenics shaped them to be the strongest
beings in the universe
and because of this they have a number
of abilities veltromites possess
super strength can fly hold their breath
in space for two weeks
and also grow a dashing mustache that
would make henry cavill in justice
league jealous
i wonder who this guy is based on now
they also become stronger the older they
get
and their rate of aging slows to a crawl
meaning that they can live for
thousands and thousands of years all
while still looking middle aged
however they do have one big weakness
and in the comics cecil stedman
discovers what this is
after his battle with his father mark is
severely comatosed
and cecil ends up studying the character
in order to uncover a way to defeat him
should he ever go rogue it's real that
veltromites have highly sensitive ears
and when cecil ends up enlisting mark to
work alongside him
he gives the character an inner ear
communicator on the surface this just
seems like something that he will use to
keep in touch with him
but he actually has far more nefarious
plans the device can also emit a
high-end frequency that completely
destroys mark's equilibrium
and this knocks him off balance now
because both mark and nolan existed on
earth for a long time
they also share a common weakness that
we all have
in episode 8 it's revealed that in
america's drinking water there is a
certain chemical which means a range of
light is imperceptible to both
our eyes and the veltromites this means
that cecil can hide certain things from
mark
and before launching his attack on the
character he actually takes him to the
white room before unleashing the rihanna
men on him
cecil hammers the high frequency alarm
and this causes mark to be almost
completely paralyzed
the rihanna men begin to kick the crap
out of him and though he escapes and
flies across the planet
cecil uses his teleportation device to
follow him
setting the device off every step of the
way this is a key
part of our plan so just in case you
haven't prepared to fight him yet
then i suggest you set 40 billion
dollars to the side
to build such a device now mark manages
to make it to the guardians of the globe
who are furious to discover that cecil
has done them dirtier than fredo
corleone
this is how mark manages to beat cecil
but it could have played out a lot worse
for the character
now in the veltromite war we see several
of their other weaknesses play out
and not to get too spoilery but one does
die by being tossed into the sun
so there's there's another one for you
there just make sure you've got a sun
lying around
now on top of this we also learn of
something called the scourge virus
which is basically a virus that wipes
out 99.9 percent of all the veltromites
it's so powerful that humans don't stand
a chance against it
and it's one of the most dangerous
diseases in the entire universe
at one point in the comics mark actually
gets infected by this
and leads to him losing his powers now
he survives because he's a pure blood
that's connected to the royal dynasty
but by that very thinking nolan is too
thus we can completely remove almost all
of his powers with this viral strain
and leave him as weak as that one guy
who thumbs down every video
the minute after it's released you know
who you are yeah you loser now
interestingly
when nolan first came to earth and
encountered cecil he told him the bs
story about beltrum which stated that it
was a peaceful planet
intent on doing good things throughout
the galaxy at the time
cecil and the gda actually suspected
that this was a lie
but they didn't put any contingency
plans in place purely because
earth needed a protector i think that
this is where cecil could have actually
started to formulate something
that would have been key to defeating
nolan and in our plans
it's the starting point now after
fighting the guardians of the globe
i say fighting was it was pretty
one-sided the character was left
hospitalized
whilst his body healed this would have
been the perfect opportunity to study
his dna
and discover the high frequency weakness
that all veltromites have
unable to move you could inject a device
into his head
much like how cecil did with mark that
would allow you to trigger the high
frequency noise
that pretty much disables veltromites
across the board
after throwing an exploding house in
kaiju at him
you could then lure the character to the
white room and in here move silently
now we do see through the rihanna men
that using the same light technology
here
that it is possible to turn yourself
invisible though never explicitly stated
it's likely that cecil's security guards
too have this within their uniforms
and this is how they are able to operate
undetected in fact when they're in
nolan's home
up until he suspects something is up he
has no idea they're moving amongst the
furniture
and possessing this technology would be
the key to bringing him down
in the white room you yeah i'm talking
to you you wouldn't want to take any
chances that he might sniff you out
and it's at this point that i'd suggest
you activate the inner ear implant that
would have him looking like your uncle
knobhead
dancing at a wedding whilst mark escaped
through the ceiling in order to get away
if i was you i would teleport out of the
white room at this point
and unleash the scourge virus which
would disable his powers and abilities
the virus would be contained completely
because of this and it also would mean
that you wouldn't get infected
now i think the big issue in cecil's
plan is that he constantly threw things
at the character
instead of focusing on weakening him
before unleashing his armada
because we can't toss omniman into the
sun we need a way to bring the sun to us
and thus it's at this point that you
should unleash the satellite which has
been channeling the energy of the star
in order to weaponize it firing this
laser at the white room would not only
kill nolan
but it would also destroy everything
inside of it including the skurge virus
meaning that you don't get another 2020
and let's be honest uh
most of 2021 it has been pretty crap as
well
now nolan would finally be dead at this
point and you could relax knowing that
you'd save not only the entire planet
but also that debbie was single hey get
yourself away
well it's that plan it's amazing yeah
it's foolproof and the best way to kill
the character
there's also another one that having
talked about which would work amazingly
just give him pictures of spider-man
yeah and that should calm him right down
now obviously i'd love to hear how you'd
beat nolan so comment below and let me
know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of may in which we're
giving away three copies of the godzilla
vs kung collection
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on how to beat nolan
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of our season 2
predictions
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the comic [ __ ] that was
shown at the ending of episode 8
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more by the way thank
you for sitting through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace